les activités quotidiennes deviennent de
plus en plus difficile pour brigitte en
termes bergues
on va suivre la quête constante c'est du
matin quand je me lève jusqu'au soir
quand je me couche
elle attend une intervention
chirurgicale à la hanche depuis des mois
et j'ai appris par moi-même fin juillet
à l'hôpital pour vos qualités l'état de
la situation et ils m'ont dit que mon
docteur avait toujours pour recommencer
a opéré plusieurs orthopédiste québécois
ont presque stopper leurs activités en
trois mois j'ai peut être opérés trois
cas un coeur parmi d'autres qui explique
l'explosion du nombre de patients qui
attendent une chirurgie de la hanche
de janvier à juillet leur nombre est
passé de 3877 à 4919 une hausse de 26%
un problème encore plus marquée dans la
région de montréal le nombre de gens qui
attendent une chirurgie de la hanche a
augmenté de 33% pour les patients de
lille et de 45% pour ceux de la
montérégie où travaille le docteur nous
yann et ont perdu la qualité de vie
la souffrance qu'ils ont endurée et on
perd du sommeil
même problème pour les chirurgies du
genou le nombre de gens en attente a
augmenté de 6250 à cette 1979
entre janvier et juillet une hausse de
28%
partout le même problème
le personnel déplacer en chercher celle
des pour la pandémie est épuisé les
infirmières sont à 65 % de l'effectif
qu'on devrait avoir
c'est des gens qui ont été nos anges
gardiens pendant la pandémie et sont
épuisés et ont pas pris leurs vacances
le premier ministre affirme que son
gouvernement un plan pour régler ce
problème
on s'était donné un plein pour faire un
rattrapage du côté des chirurgies puis
d'ailleurs on est en avance sur le plan
mais brigitte un terreau berg s'attend
quand même à devoir être patient mais
pas d'argent sur 2020 mois d'après moi
si je chante ce serait quelque part à
l'hiver 2021 ici david gêne-t-il et
radio canada montréal